[Music]  hmm that's what it was like missus this  is not fake video listen to the CBBC  have a dramatic and embarrassing  technical glitch last night there was a  technical problem just a few seconds  before the news at 10 went on the air so  the anchor his name is Hugh Edwards just  sat there in silence while they fix the  problem it took for very long minutes Oh  No one viewer tweeted that seeing  Edwards sitting there looking worried at  the top castle's quote how I imagined  the world would end so I think kept  playing dunno  dad I need ya to sit there yeah in our  business that's just that painful  thankful to watch you sorry to hear that  happy boats around us in control room  want us to know never happened it was  never happen here knock on glass thank  you control room crews should we see a  shot of the control room yeah we should  yeah let's see in the control room the  people that would never let that  yes never four minutes in silence